let's be clear
this new payoffer would not have
happened without the strike action taken
by ambulance and health workers across
the NHS
thanks to their strength and dedication
the government was forced to change its
position and talk about pay
our members have voted and the results
are as follows
56 of GMB members have voted to accept
the payoffer
on a turnout of 51 percent
this means GMB Union will vote in favor
of the payoffer at the NHS staff council
meeting next week
inverting to accept the offer our
members recognize that progress has been
made
from the government originally offering
nothing health workers will be thousands
of pounds better off
it also meets a key GMB demand of a huge
pay-up lift for the lowest paid lifting
them above the real living wage
but so much more needs to be done for
workers if we are to get the NHS that we
need
GMB now needs action for our ambulance
members
starting by addressing their retirement
and on social Powers enhancement
concerns
this is the only way that government and
employers can start to seriously address
the lower morale in ambulance trusts
today is just one step in the battle to
restore NHS workers decade of lost
earnings
gnb will continue this fight so that the
NHS and ambulance workers who serve and
care for the public get the Fair Deal
that they deserve thank you
all right well let's take you off to
hearing there from gmb's National
National secretary Rachel Harrison there
uh saying that the GMB Union has decided
on a turnout of 51 to accept the
government's pay offer that was 56 of
its members voting for the uh to accept
that the government's pay offer let's go
straight to our health correspondent
Ashish Joshi he joins me now Ashish
we're awaiting uh those results we have
them now and that does put unions like
unite in a more tricky position now
that's why we were talking earlier about
the importance of of this vote the
result
um to put it all into context what it
means now is the NHS
Council that the unions and bodies that
represent health workers who are in
negotiations with the government there
is a clear majority now where this GMB
vote accepting the government's payoff
there is a clear majority of the number
of health workers who have belong to
unions who want to see the government
payoff implemented the NHS Council uses
an electoral college-style system and if
you look at the bigger unions like unite
Unison GMB and the Royal College of
Nursing there is a clear division we
heard from unite this morning they have
rejected the government's offer we had
heard earlier about the Royal College of
Nursing they had rejected the
government's offer but when you take
this GMB vote together with unison and
all the other medium-sized and smaller
unions that means that staff Council the
the majority is now with unions who want
to accept the government's payoff they
will meet next week on Tuesday and if
everyone's got their sounds right and it
seems like it's quite clear-cut at this
moment then the staff Council will go to
government and say we accept your
payoffer and it's likely that the
government will Implement its pay offer
on all of those unions whether they have
voted to accept or reject but the
problem there is we have already heard
from unite this morning and they said
they will continue with their strike
action they say that the the rules of
the NHS staff Council aren't legally
binding so we could see here unions are
like unite breaking away from the NHS
staff Council and plowing their own
forum and trying to go It Alone with
industrial actions and Strikes but of
course what that would mean is there
will be much much fewer in number
because the majority here is certainly
with the health workers who want to
accept their government's offer it's not
an end to the strikes it's not an end to
the industrial action but it certainly
will be cheering at new use it for the
government that the GMB Union has
decided like Unison to accept their
payoff